so first off guys congrats it's an
amazingly funny film actually some very
painfully funny moments in it but really
enjoyed it and that leads to my question
what would you advise other artists who
having quite crossed over and are sort
of in that limbo that your character
matt is in in terms of maybe the
artistic guilt or peer pressure or
family pressure to sort of have this
establish life but they want another way
what's your advice to someone that's
caught in that quandary of wanting
another life but getting pressure that
thirtysomething pressure yeah it's like
I or 30 it's something pressure to
choose but settle down have a normal
existence domestic life and have a job
that it's paid and has health insurance
wow you know IRA and I get asked to two
sets of questions that we're not good at
answering and one of them is romantic
advice which were both terrible at as
you can tell if you see the film into
career advice cuz like I I feel like
like you do actually kind of have to
ignore your parents and your family when
they discourage you from doing what you
want to do I think your parents did they
actually want you to do something
besides comedy was there a specific
thing that they did my dad would just
always say like you know this in a very
supportive way you know this might
partly nicely into advertising this
whole comedy thing like no no this is it
this is the plan like this is going well
when you're like when i was making like
AI don't know 500 bucks a week driving
my mom station wagon around the country
opening for bigger comedians like I was
like success like in my mind I was like
that's I don't know how to dream was
that average at two years that's like 25
now twenty six thousand dollars a year I
was like fine great like if I can pay my
rent I'll do this for the rest of my
life I had this experience with my
parents of the they said I've said this
before and it makes them upset but it's
true they're the only Jews in America
who don't like public broadcasting and
they completely disapproved of me
working in public radio in my 20s and
we're constantly trying to get me to
Matt go to medical school which they
only stopped like after I was in my
mid-30s I feel like my parents wanted me
to go to something like medical school
but not medical school because then I
could have the potential to hurt people
wait look I botched surgery or you know
to me because I'm so clumsy like they
kind of knew like you should go to
medical school maybe not medical school
yeah something like medical school
something stable and academic but maybe
not something where you're watching
people's innards yeah take a therapy
event great yeah it would have been a
very good narrative that I think I'd
like I feel like this is one we can
answer I feel like I feel like if people
want to make stuff for a living of some
sort if they want to do some sort of
creative work they have to ignore their
families like it's an inherently it's
true dang yeah like the thing that the
character in the film was that he's in
denial about his his relationship going
south he's in denial about his his
health deteriorating sleepwalking
getting worse he's in denial about how
badly his career was going and we always
thought the kind of fun thing about that
was that that is the one strand of
denial that actually works in his favor
and that's actually I I always thought
that was kind of a neat thing about the
film is that we're not dismissing denial
entirely residential based on trees yeah
yeah I also like took a long time before
I was any good at making a radio story
listening to an interview with the henry
rollins he talked about he had an agent
who said oh don't worry sit back the
work will come just be patient and he
said no I'm not going to accept that I'm
gonna go ahead and book myself so I am
having had the successful career you've
had for years what would you say to my
kit to all of us on thriving and
sustaining career in this business this
business being the movie business movie
business radio and me where you're sort
of out there in front of the view I
think she just means losing artistic
battles okay look inherently like uphill
creative our jobs anyone struggling in
that what do you suggest that's a
question yeah what's your what's the
piece of sort of is there a mission
statement is their mantra or someone
could sustain and thrive at the same
time or is that not possible for years
what would you say
you're sort of like an answer oh good go
for it baby good well I feel like um do
it's like do what you love and do it
inspires you when you see it that makes
you feel something or make makes you
want to do that thing but also listen to
people's criticism like I feel like that
one mistake I feel like I see comedians
make because comedians tend to be it
might myself included it's done people
but is when comedians or any other
artists are just kind of like no it's my
way and and I just and they don't want
to take criticism you have to take
criticism from people you trust you know
IRA and I I feel like thrive on that in
terms of he's really critical and it had
like we thought it'd help surround
ourselves with people who could take our
work and and we change our work and it's
a constant process of trying to make the
work better we do you just gave me a
signal like there's a shorter you mean
shorten is that to me is it but can I
say like I think I think the most
important thing if you're making work is
that first of all you're amusing
yourself and it sure that's true even if
you're doing reporting you know if
you're doing journalism I feel like
young journalists they're always told
like about the important mission there
on but nobody ever says like follow
what's super interesting to you now work
will be good because of that and and
then and then I think in terms of the
business side of it you know you know
now there are so many ways that you can
actually get work out to people and and
make it happen and even with this film
you know like like we had never made a
movie before and and IFC is a great
distributor distributes lots of
independent films and they were able to
get us into 34 theaters using the normal
ways they did it which is a lot we're a
small no I for a first-time movie and
and then we went to fans of Mike's of
hands of the radio show and said like
hey we would love for you to see this in
a film you know contact tweet at email
call your local theater and ask the
hashtag bring sleepwalk and have them
have them bring the film and we jumped
from 34 to 150 theater now
150 theaters yes from fans reaching out
and I feel I get every at every stage
we've tried to use whatever tiny
foothold we have to just try to get the
workout so and I say that's I
didn't feel like anybody who's excited
about their own work and ambitious tries
to do that but yeah I feel like I've
been doing that the thing that we did
with the theaters i feel like i've been
doing that since day one in stand-up
comedy like when i was an emcee at the
DC improv making like 50 bucks a night i
had at the end of the show i had like a
list out sign up for my email list since
like I was terrible no one should have
signed up but I stayed in touch about
the people